ああ
うん
いやーこんな笹で見せたですながらやってませんでしたムーンポーこーだやっていき
たいと思います宜しくお願いいたしますよろしくお願いします外に出た時に市長さんと
かにたまに会ったりするんですけども
よく言われるのが分豪雨の動画を出してくださいってすごい言われてまして御夏
バーナーの需要が&かな
思ってるんですけどあーみたいなんで出させて頂きます今晴れでもうちょっと3月号
終わって新生活に立つまでちょっと文房具気になってる方多いと思うので是非学生さん
とかをすることでデスクワークがある方とかよかったら見ていってくださいませ
[音楽]
凄い漫画ですだいぶ前に買ったんですよねただ調べたところ希少下げてまたはから予約
してまで買ったんですけどもこちらの商品ですかっこか愚作座でもを下げないですこう
レンズメロデス
はいをレンズっていうのは僕だいぶ昔に紹介したことがあると思うんですけども全然僕
なんでこれで火をつけたかといいますとなんか普通のレンズと違うんですよねご覧
くださいませ
俺
レンズネロのユーザーの口コミが欲し郷中 v max でございます max って
すごい気になる値段なんですけどだいたい相場をみるとどこも2000円吠えている
めちゃくちゃ高いんですよアマゾンで見た目は2500円2790円とかいやば
3000円で売ってると困るじゃんぼったくりか気が移動だと5600円ではで打っ
てるよこれ
これはよくないん
俺が紹介することによってさらに高くなってしまうことだが
させて頂きたいけれどもなるねええええ
あり a 10にか0.2と0.3がある日だけ
0.2がちょっと高めみたいですとりあえず笹が挙げてみましょうか
our
はいはいはいはいはいめっちゃシンプルここが尖ってるから結構背付かしらね
持つところちょっと下下げさせるんですけどなんかすぐ研ぎ澄まされた黒いデザインに
なっておりますこちら0.3ですね俺ん0
ポイッ
なって0.3
ねえて号買っちゃったよ見た目がすごい高級ポイスでヤバくないんだってさん
2000円ってやばくねぇ
ただどうやらペンテルさんが出せるサーフィンの最高峰クラスのシャーペンらしいで頭
を呼ばせて頂きますと
っとなるほどねはいあのをレンズってやったら言う普通のレンズ普通のレンズじゃあし
芯が折れないよっていうだけの売りだったんですけどもをレンズネロ何がすごいかと
いいますと
シャー芯が折れない+延々にパーシングでずケットが何だろうなぁちょっと他の代謝
名前だとあれなんですけども僕の立場からたら出せる気がします言わせていただきます
くるとが来るとがあってあれ中国で回ってとずっとさあ疹が出るから無下に書き続ける
んですけどもちゃん死んだ俺ないをレンズかつ無限にか
着続けることができる機能が合体したのがをレンズ nero らしいですぼく車線
基本的に0.5死んじゃうんですけどこれすごいだけですねうんいやまいいオレない俺
ないっていう
あっ
なくなりそう
もう一時期僕が2をご利用しした最強のサーベイスマッシュを彷彿させる書やさですね
メロっていう言葉はイタリア語で黒って見出しです強いね芯の折れないをレンズ
システムトドック不要の自動死んだし機構
もう最強ですね0.3の写真買ってこよちょっとワイナーを捨てるシャーペンの
スラッシュも持って来ましたこのひとつちょっと見比べてみましょう
時てどうでしょうか右顔レンズネロ左がスマッシュです謎やっぱこうみたね加速にて
ますねペンテルさんのシャーペンの最終形態は問題かこういうプロの方中感じっていう
イメージらしいですね
なんかもいろいろとすごい似てる
気がしますねいやねー
八景置いてあるだけでかっけーいやこんなん使ったらまずモーモーテルズ
めっちゃかっこいいじゃんコレ阪急けど実際に変えてみましょう
まったく問題なくかけますをれないっていうのがわかってるからすごい力強くかけるの
がポイントですね
0.3と思わせないかでその力強くかけます例えば疹が出続けるところかなそこは
すごいと思いますね
あとこのねつぶつぶモッセの方のつぶつぶもすごい書きやすい野菜ではこれ最強なん
じゃないかってけどいやーなんか勉強したくなっちゃうなぁや
素晴らしい書後コツですそんなくるとがみたいな壁コンベコー沈む感じが
ほぼないですね大大大大ないやーこれすごいなぁ
強いで皆さんいかがだったでしょうか俺ネロは芯を出さないで書くシャープペンシル
です
0.3で細い字も書けるし0.3だって俺のイメージがあるんですけどもオレンジなん
でおれない
滑滝かけしてると a に写真が出続けてをノックする必要がないでこの持ちやすさと
書きやす
たねスマッシュに結構似たところがありますが来るたがのいいとこどりずっと書き続け
られる日というのがついてるんで
コーンレアすげーなー誰かに戦もするし結構高いんですけど
ぜひなんか今年受験生とか今年は勉強を頑張りたいとかお父さんお母さん見ていまし
たら子供へのプレゼントにこの高級シャーペン一本ぐだけどいいんじゃないですかね
めっちゃ宣伝みたいになってますけど
本当に純正にいいなって思いましたこれは今をわからないんですけど惟光死なず状態
だったみたいでと手に入れられるかわかんないんですけどもぜひ使ってみてはいかが
でしょうか
あの僕の話になるんですけども最近ダイエットしててすごいしんどいです
じゃあな
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ